Okay, I have loaded a timeline trace I have saved from an earlier session.
>> Wait, wait. You can save timeline traces?
>> Oh yeah. It's a pretty awesome feature.
You can just right click on the timeline
and save any trace. Similarly, you can load
a trace from a previous session in the
same way. This is a really useful feature
whenever you're debugging a site, and want to
keep it for further analysis or if you need to share it with someone. Hm. Wow.
All right, I've been taking screen shots. Really wish I'd known about his early.
>> Yeah, traces are definitely better than screen shots. I've
put a link to the trace we're looking at here in
the instructor notes. Why don't you download it and open it
on your machine to follow along. I'll wait a few seconds.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay. Let's look for some CSS events in this trace. First, you can see the CSS
requests going out. Note that it happens after
the first trunk of HTML, is received. This
is where the parser finds the link tag
and initiates the CSS request. Then we wait
to get the css bites and finally a
bit later we see the recalculate style event which
is were we convert the css response into the css
object model. In this particular case the css is tiny so
it only takes a few milliseconds to do the conversion,
but for larger style sheets this could definitely take much longer.
>> Okay, so before I rewrite all of my css rules. I should
probably record the timeline and check out how long this stuff is taking, right?
>> That's right. Measure first then optimize as needed.